so roxroy my fellow time traveler it is
so sad to see you go
and based on last night's episode it
looked like you were surprised was it a
blind side
um i was i was surprised um i was
surprised uh
a lot because i thought mike would have
given me a heads up um i grew up in new
york he grew up in new jersey i thought
we made like a barn like that robot like
hey i look out for you you look out for
me
you know so i was a little shocked i
turned around i looked at him i said
whoa that was like seriously but at the
same time you know it is survivor
you never know when a blind side is
coming
and uh
you know i just i try to live in that
moment where at that point i said wow
raj man look how poor you got
a hundred percent and
i think what was interesting about that
tribal council is you were saying i felt
like it was a mellow day today so now
that knowing that hindsight is 2020 do
you think that there were signs that you
might have been in trouble
uh a little bit um
i saw
um like
it's not it wasn't shown but i saw how i
was behaving romeo was very quiet and as
i thought our alliance was good but we
never really spoke
but at the same time you know i as they
showed last night i said to the guys
let's get together i
try to build that bond a little bit that
if trouble is coming you look out for me
i'll look out for you
um a part of me felt as if yes something
but at the same time
the logical part of my brain was like
you know dude
if if if something was coming up
trust your alliance trust trust you
think they would someone say something
to you obviously it didn't work out
well we saw omar hai and mike all flip
on you i know you had mentioned you had
this bond with mike but do you think
that there was one betrayal that cut a
little deeper or was it just all part of
the game
i think it was all part of the game um i
don't take i don't take any
anyone's right my name besides if
besides someone spelling my name wrong
uh i don't take anything i said i took
nothing from it uh it is what it is i
was just so uh incredibly humbled
just to be able to experience what i did
for as long as i did um so it is what it
is what it was
okay so noted your name doesn't have an
x in it
so in the episode there was a lot of
focus at the beginning about your idea
to build this all men's alliance do you
think that that was your downfall in the
game
no um
i don't know if that was a downfall
um i think i did a lot of
self-reflection during the game i think
in the beginning i think the first
episode i even looked at dre and i said
am i am i coming off too strong i think
one of the times i got back and i said
my social game sucks right now so there
was a lot of self-reflection um in terms
of my social part of it i i was able to
be isolated for two and a half days not
knowing what was going on
got thrown back with everyone um i saw a
competitor in jonathan i saw a
competitor in mike um i i love competing
i love going at it it's like i said why
not guys just stick together one of the
things they didn't show though is
i said as long as we make a guy alliance
traders terry has to come with us
because i was like dream needs to come
with us in this alliance um because
you know i i was looking out for her we
had this kind of we had a bond um out
there um but i don't think it was my
downfall i think i was just trying to
increase my social game whereas
i'm gonna look out for you you can trust
in me you look out for me in a gu ice
term and then like a guy's meeting maybe
it sounds a little whatever but i was
just looking out in terms of that you
know they they had big personalities um
so i wanted to play off of that mm-hmm
well i think in terms of what you did
socially i think that what really stuck
out is how much gratitude you had for
the experience and i think that even
though you were surprised when you got
voted out when you got your torch
snuffed you were wishing people good
luck you really commended them for the
gameplay so i think that that really
stuck out and when you look back at the
game is there anything you would have
done differently
i'm sorry can you repeat that yeah what
would i have done differently yeah like
when you look back at your game as a
whole is there anything you would have
done differently
um
no
uh and and you know what
my experience um was so fulfilling
that
um it was a majority vote for me
to get me out and that says something
you know there was there was and
no one said they got
i no one said at the moment or or
anything they got written because i did
this i no it was more like
by rocks
have a nice like that was it so i have
no regrets about anything i don't i
don't think that the way i played the
game uh out there and being who i am i
was true to who i am um i said what i
did i did what i said and that was it um
i was reliable in that in that factor to
my team my tribe mates and after we
merged they kind of knew where i kind of
stood and that was it
so i want to
get into the tribal council that
happened after you were eliminated
because when all of the other castaways
walked into that tribal council everyone
was shocked to see you on the jury so
what was going through your head at that
moment
well i need to set up this circumstance
it was pouring rain jeff just snuffed me
out
uh the first person that walks in is
drea she looks over she's like whoa two
brown people are sitting there
not only that
my alliance who i'm very tight with is
sitting there what just happened because
they had no clue um
i i kind of
just made that moment just happened um
i sat there i didn't really show much
emotion um at all and i did that on
purpose because um i wanted that motion
that that moment just to play out i i
felt very emotional inside
um not because i was voted out but i saw
someone that i cared a lot about with
her head down
just like trying to understand and try
to wrap herself around what the hell
just happened and i just wanted that
moment to be the moment uh for
you know
everything uh so
it was it was really tough
um
it was it was really tough to re-watch
what happened it was really really tough
but at the same time in the moment that
i was
there
you just have to let the game
play out in front of you because while
you're sitting there there ain't nothing
you can say
nothing you're going to say is going to
change anything you're not a part until
the end uh so just let it be
and as the conversation unfolded i think
it's going to be one of the most
memorable conversations we've seen at a
tribal council you're sitting on the
jury you're beside chanel what are you
thinking as you're seeing this all play
out
um
i'm thinking that
there's past experience in both um drea
and marianne's life
that
has made their decision what it was that
they would come up front and say i'm not
going to be the third brown person
sitting there that's on them
i was also thinking that jonathan
you got two ears and one mouth
shut up
just listen
be
be that person just to be like
let it go nothing against jonathan i
like john but
let it go bro just let it go because
there's there this is raw
this is something that
socially
it's it's hard to actually convey
how you can talk about certain things
sometimes but
when peop when you see that raw emotion
when you see how someone is interpreting
things
just
let it be in that moment and that's it
what happened is
what it is and that's the end of it
for me at least for me that was
that was enough said
for me i didn't need to you know the
moment is the moment
beautifully said and i think that
there's so much that happened in that
moment that was so illuminating and so
brave and so vulnerable and
your ally drea talking about
how she had to consider the way she
spoke and she acted before she went into
the game and then seeing the way that
marian andrea decided to act with
bravery um and decide to play their
idols in spite of you know what whatever
criticism can come to them for speaking
their truth so
what does that mean to you to see people
that you are close to like that
making those decisions and really
playing with with their heart on their
sleeve
well you know it drew it uh what you
just it drew me back to like my
experience being by myself for two days
because you're outside of the game and i
was very
i felt very honored and and and um
almost like i needed that moment just to
decompress
so
you're always so hyper focused about
everything and that's happening in the
game
um that moment that we watched last
night was
pulled out of just you're out of the
game for a minute
so that was just pulling yourself away
from it and getting back to like i said
they were pulling in on their past
experience and their past um you know
just feelings about things and it kind
of pulled you out of it and made you it
made me actually feel as if like i was
i was um
i was back
like away from everything like i was
just you know
just just away from the game for for for
a little bit um so it was
i wouldn't say
i i think i think the moment speaks for
itself
that's that's how i feel about it the
moment spoke for itself
yeah and i think it's amazing to see
even now that the game is over and the
episode is aired you are still in
support of your ally drea and i think
that that says a lot too
now i want to
go back in time see what i did there
because you and i have a special bond
you and i are the only people who had
that exile experience where we smashed
the hourglass so what were you thinking
about when you were making that decision
uh i actually thought a lot about that
decision um i thought in my head it
wasn't a very easy decision to make um i
always thought like for me
a winner is the winner you won
okay let's go forward
okay
and then i said to myself
rox you've gotten
so many times in your life where you got
to do over you got you redemption for
something maybe i maybe i i didn't
deserve it but i got i got to do over to
do stuff and i said to myself um
i looked at
my alliance and i think the split was
different
i think i would have kept the hourglass
but the split wasn't different i had
two people that from jump from day one
romeo drayer we said we're gonna be in a
bond so we're gonna be good i said
i'm gonna help them today i'm gonna do
that i didn't know mike i didn't know
omar and i didn't know you know nothing
about them but
i'm uh i think i showed in the game that
what i said i did what i did i like
that's it i did what i said i said what
i did and that's it so i continued that
trend um
being on that island uh for those for
those two and a half days
uh it really humbled me as just a person
to ex to to know that i am such uh
a few to get to play this game but also
just to experience
the beauty the joy the stuff
of fiji and everything it was was
incredible
i mean i selfishly was excited to see
you go to exile because i'm thinking i'm
going to relive the experience i'm going
to see rock roxroy overcome the
struggles i had on exile and then you
were thriving you built this palace you
put me to shame in terms of the way you
lived on exile so
i had a good laugh watching you and i
was really proud of you but i know that
being out there for two days is life
changing
so
what is the lesson you're going to take
away from your time on exile and from
your time on survivor
uh that we're we're just a
grain of sand in in time like it's you
know sometimes you just gotta
look around and enjoy the beauty and
then appreciate um um the
the the experience the the fortune that
you get um
you your experience was definitely
different than mine because for me i was
like if it rains i'm not getting away so
i pulled myself up but um but uh i took
away a lot from the fact as i said you
know i have a eye
eye disease that um i know that
potentially could be detrimental to me
in the future
and um
just to see and enjoy the beauty of life
of um
of
it
it it it really
just
like i like that was
my
million dollar
uh check those two and a half day
experience personally um because um
not a lot of
people ever get to
live
see
what i what you and i saw um so i was
very humbled by it and um i will always
cherish it
there's something about living there for
those two days that just gives you a
different perspective on everything and
you're right we're just grains of sand
maybe we're grains of sand in an
hourglass um but it was honestly so
inspiring to see you really take all of
the joy that you could out of your
survivor journey so roxroy i want to say
thank you so much for putting yourself
out there and i wish you all of the best
you